simple fact
that we're here in person
is a key indication as president biden
will remind us in just a bit
that we are building a better america
while we continue to face real
challenges
from russian aggression to inflation
as the president said in his state of
the union address
we are stronger today
than we were a year ago
and we will be stronger a year from now
than we are today
and in so many ways
your communities
have led the charge
i have the privilege of driving
president biden's domestic policy agenda
in the white house
and across the federal government
from health care
to economic mobility
to rural and urban policy
so today i want to highlight the work
we've been doing together
to tackle three urgent and at times
interconnected challenges
rising gun crime
our mental health crisis
and the opioid epidemic
when it comes to keeping our communities
safe
we're working to build trust between law
enforcement and the communities they're
sworn to serve
because we should not have to choose
between public safety
and public trust
last june the president laid out his
comprehensive strategy
to tackle gun crime and help make our
communities safer
we're reigning in the proliferation of
ghost guns
we're expanding employment opportunities
in after school and summer programming
we're helping formerly incarcerated
individuals successfully re-enter their
communities
and we're investing in two key
strategies that we know work
community policing
and community violence interventions
and we're just getting started
the bipartisan funding agreement just
enacted by congress
invests nearly 4 billion dollars for
state and local law enforcement and
crime prevention programs
a 15
increase
[Applause]
and president biden continues to press
for an historic five billion dollars in
evidence-based
community violence intervention programs
additionally cities across the country
are already leveraging hundreds of
billions in american rescue plan dollars
to reduce gun crime
here in washington d.c
the city has deployed 50 new violence
interrupters in two dozen neighborhoods
los angeles county and milwaukee are
prioritizing job training and employment
for young people
tulsa is providing three thousand dollar
stipends to hire more police officers
because as president biden has made
clear
the way to tackle violent crime
isn't to defund the police it's to fund
accountable police with the resources
and training
with the resources and training they
need to protect our communities
and as we near the summer
when gun crime typically increases
i'd like to make an urgent plea
if you have already committed american
rescue plan funding to reduce gun crime
consider doubling down
if you haven't yet
now is the time
and don't just commit funding deploy
those dollars swiftly
before the summer
we can save lives right now
so let's do it
[Applause]
a second area of top priority
is our mental health crisis
two out of five
adults
report symptoms of anxiety or depression
and one in three high schoolers
say they've experienced persistent
feelings of sadness
or hopelessness
this is unprecedented
that's why we've dedicated 5.5 billion
dollars just over the last year
the most federal funding in history
to address mental health and substance
use
[Applause]
president biden as part of our unity
agenda
called for a major transformation in how
the nation
approaches mental health
that means dramatically expanding our
mental health workforce and system
capacity
like bringing more and more diverse
providers
into behavioral health
and launching the 988 crisis response
line
[Applause]
it means connecting more people to care
from expanding telehealth
to improving insurance coverage for
mental health
and it means creating healthy
environments including instituting
stronger protections for our young
people online
here again our cities are leading the
way
for example columbus ohio
has leveraged arp and other relief funds
to hire an additional 28 school
counselors
with plans for each school in the
district to have a full-time counselor
[Applause]
just think what that might mean
to a student coping with the upheaval
of the last several years
someone to talk to
about their academic and social
pressures
perhaps a shoulder to lean on
while grieving a lost family member
for so many young people
this
is a game changer
for some
it could be a lifesaver
so let's make these investments in our
kids health
and well-being
finally and relatedly
we're working to address the devastating
opioid epidemic
that steals an american life
once every seven minutes
this is a public health crisis
demanding a public health
response and it requires a unified
response
all of our communities have been touched
by the pain of overdose
and addiction
and all of us
must be part of the solution
that's why president biden also made
addressing this epidemic
part of our unity agenda
and why the bipartisan funding agreement
congress just passed
will empower communities like yours to
meet this epidemic head on
we're investing in prevention
by funding coalitions to build drug-free
communities from miami florida
to sitka alaska
we're prioritizing harm reduction
meaning a responder on a college campus
in santa barbara can access naloxone and
get trained in using it to reverse an
overdose
we're removing outdated barriers to
treatment
to make it easier for a primary care
doctor in sioux city
to prescribe life-saving medication to
her patients
struggling with opioid addiction
and we're working to reduce the supply
of illicit drugs
including cracking down on traffickers
and seizing more than 15 000 pounds of
fentanyl last year
[Applause]
addressing any one of these challenges
is a tall order
but i've been inspired by the efforts of
local leaders like you
last month i accompanied president biden
and mayor adams in new york city
we joined a daily meeting where federal
state and local law enforcement
share intelligence to take repeat
shooters
off the streets
we also met with community violence
intervention leaders
nobody hid behind slogans
they didn't get hung up on ideology
everyone was just rolling up their
sleeves
and solving problems
it was public service
at its best
and it gave me renewed confidence that
we can and we will
build a stronger and more equitable
future
for our cities
and our nation
that is the task before us
that's what this moment demands
and that is the america we can and must
deliver for the people we serve
thank you for all you do for the
citizens of this country thank you for
your leadership and your support
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
how y'all doing
how about susan rice
all right
look
i got you all
i got them
i even got susan rice a little
nervous but anyway look uh this is all
about having fun i love y'all and there
ain't nothing you can do about it
our next speaker knows all about
challenges and opportunities we have a
local we have as local leaders of
america
he began his political career serving on
the newcastle
county council in delaware
he knows from experience
that intergovernmental
cooperation is critical to our country
with that in mind he championed direct
and flexible federal relief for local
governments when kovitt hit our shores
a year ago the american rescue plan act
was signed into law
you need to get up off your feet right
now
since then oprah has made a difference
in the lives of millions of americans
and has empowered us all local leaders
to fulfill our piece of the promise to
our cities towns and villages thanks to
the funding of opera my hometown in
fulton county georgia union city served
1500 households with emergency rental
assistance to help them pay rent or
utilities as we weathered the storm of
the pandemic
now
it is my deep and humble honor to
announce the president
of these united states of america
joe
biden
[Music]
hello hello hello
it's great to be back at all in person
this time please sit down please sit
down
if you have a seat
mr president mayor
vince williams
thank you for your leadership of this
organization your leadership
down in union city georgia
[Applause]
i wanted to come here because you're the
people america looks to first for
guidance and for leadership and that's
not hyperbole
city managers mayors council persons
when you have a problem
they're knocking on your doors
that's because
their quality of life depends on you
more than anyone else
and i'm not trying to be solicitous
i know from personal experience
when i was a 27 year old kid
i got elected to the new castle county
council which uh
we're like a miniature illinois one
county has 60 of the population of the
state
and so the councilman
represents a district seven times bigger
than the state rep and
three times
bigger than a state senator
and uh
fortunately
after two years i was elected for four
years
after two years my
the republican party saw on me something
i didn't see
so they reapportioned me to a two-year
term
from a district that was overwhelmingly
republican to over-overwhelmingly
republican
so i got put in the position that old
saying goes up or out
so i do appreciate what you all do
i uh i really mean it you're you're
there
you can't walk into a grocery store or
gas station you can't go in a
supermarket without without someone
having a question for you and because
you're the you're the people i know
you're the people they depend on
you're out there every day on the front
lines of public service
and that's why when i took office last
year in the midst of the worst
health pandemic in a century
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
i knew we had to design a rescue plan
with your partnership to meet your needs
three days ago marked the one-year
anniversary i signed the american rescue
plan
i'm
[Applause]
i learned as a councilman
i never have anything that's intended to
be shared by the cities and towns that
has to go through a state legislature
well i mean it
the most significant investment in local
government and all of history is in that
plan
and frankly you couldn't have gotten it
done without your support so many local
officials around the country i don't
need to remind you
the situation you all inherited in 2020
the pain
the disruption the stress of your local
budgets requiring you to lay off cops
firefighters teachers
so many people lost their jobs
and to remember
the lines of cars stretching for miles
in your communities with families just
waiting for a box of food to be put in
the backseat of the trunk
because of this law
we're able to help 41 million americans
put food on the table for the better
part of a year
because of this law
to help keep a roof over four million
people's heads
and it gave what families what my dad
would call just a little bit of
breathing room and a tough time
and it worked
because we took action america added
6.7 million jobs last year
more jobs created in one year than ever
before in american history
and hadn't stopped
we're now well over 7 million jobs
678 000 just last month
the unemployment rate is down to 3.8
percent the economy grew at
5.7 percent last year
the strongest growth in four decades
leading financial
team on wall street moody's estimated
because of the rescue plan
four million more jobs were created and
unemployment is lower by two percent
than it would have been had we failed to
act
one year after signing this law
our cities our towns and our rural
communities are roaring back
before this law
state and local governments were still
down more than a million jobs from
before the pandemic
one year later
we had at least one year of state local
job growth the largest in 20 years
adding
467 thousand jobs
educators firefighters
police officers back on the job
before this law fewer than half our
schools are open
putting an extraordinary strain on
parents and teachers and students
one year later more than 99 of our
schools are open and kids are back in
the classroom
and folks
you just had the strongest year of
hiring teachers and educators on record
but there's more to a story than that
america has had many recoveries in the
past
but underneath those recoveries
there's also been a lot of lasting pain
lots of folks
never get back on their feet when
they're knocked down so badly
a whole lot of young people
saw their futures dim from the previous
recession
they never got back on their feet
it's what economists call
economic scarring
chronic pain
when the economy comes back but some
folks are still left behind
trapped in long-term unemployment
eviction and foreclosure
research shows
that when you're stuck in that cycle
that has the worst impact on your
emotional health
than the loss of a family member which
sounds excessive but it's true
and it's serious
so when i came to office
in the midst of this crisis i was
determined
not to let that happen again this time
around
the american rescue plan we made a
choice to bring everyone along every
single person in america
so not only
as the unemployment rate dropped at a
record pace we've all seen the biggest
drop in long-term unemployment ever
recorded in a 12-month span
nearly 2.5 million people breaking out
of that cycle of long-term unemployment
and depression
black unemployment fell by more than 30
percent
hispanic unemployment fell from nearly 9
to 4.4
the fastest drop ever recorded
and we've seen
with something we should be doing again
but i'm having trouble getting it passed
again
and that is the child tax credit
the lowest poverty child poverty rate
projected in 40 years a 40-year decline
folks
we also have the lowest number of home
foreclosures ever recorded a record low
of credit card delinquencies because
families had more money in their pockets
the list goes on but you all know it
better than i do
a big part of the reason we're so
successful is because the rescue plan
went directly to you without having to
pass go without having to go to the
state house
folks
we allocated 350 billion dollars of
state and local budgets but we made sure
130 billion of that went straight to
local governments straight to local
government
six thousand local governments never got
a dime of the early relief package
exactly and enacted before i came to
office
but we made sure that every one of you
was dealt in the rescue plan
as a former local official i know that
it matters
having that flexibility and control to
meet both the short-term and the
long-term challenges you face
one year later the rescue plan is still
delivering
so i urge you all
to use the flexibility we built in the
law
to spend these funds wisely to reduce
violence in your communities
like members are doing in baton rouge in
baltimore
and in new york city
to address homelessness and affordable
housing
like you're doing in tacoma and new york
city
to expand high-speed internet like
brownsville texas
or to train
people for good paying jobs like you're
doing in oklahoma city
and by the way
there are a lot of jobs coming to people
that you're going to need to train up
people
thanks to the bipartisan infrastructure
bill
everybody knew when you heard from my
secretary a little bit earlier
america has fallen behind in
infrastructure we used to be number one
in the world
we're now number eight
but now not only is infrastructure week
finally arrive
we're talking about infrastructure
decade not week
folks
rivera authorized 4 000 projects all
across the country including 1 500
bridges of disrepair and they're
starting this year not later this year
and the law is going to create millions
of jobs rebuilding americans roads
bridges highways ports and airports
getting rid of poisonous lead pipes
and 10 million homes and 400 000 schools
so kids and families can have clean
drinking water
[Applause]
folks
we're investing 65 billion dollars to
deliver high-speed internet
everywhere in america
urban rural suburban tribal communities
we can't be a country
where a mother has to take her kid to
the mcdonald's parking lot to do their
homework over the internet
this is united states of america for
god's sake
and folks
the law is going to put an end to that
obviously and the only it's only the
beginning
hundreds of billions of new investments
are on the way
today secretary buttages announced
409 million in new grants
70 new projects 39 states just the
beginning
electric buses to make bus servers safer
more reliable environmentally sound
helping folks in big cities small towns
get to work and get to school
projects like a new 15 million dollar
bus maintenance facility serving atlanta
5 million to buy cleaner more reliable
hydrogen fuel cells for buses
replacing old diesel engines
in south and southern nevada
so much more
it's now time for cities and towns to
get ready
you don't have to wait until these
infrastructure projects start
you're going to need more welders
pipefitters advanced manufacturers
and it takes training to get the job
done well
and that's why all these programs these
apprenticeship programs union programs
and by the way when people talk about an
apprenticeship program we're talking
like going to four years of college it's
four years
that's why they're the best workers in
the world when they finish
projects are cheaper because they last
longer and they're better
you can't you can start by investing in
those rescue plan funds now
and new pathways to better jobs through
union-based apprenticeships and
on-the-job training build strong diverse
workforce you need to take on these
infrastructure jobs
so the families in your communities can
deal themselves into this booming
economy
look
we have an incredible opportunity ahead
of us but despite the progress we made
we know that families are still
struggling with higher prices
i grew up in a family where the price of
gas went up at the pump gas station
we talked about it at the kitchen table
let's be absolutely clear about why
prices are high now
they're high for two reasons
one was covet
the way the global economy works
the factory in taiwan that makes
computer chip shuts down due to a covet
outbreak
it causes a ripple effect to slow down
auto manufacturing in detroit literally
not figuratively
so because of the pandemic
we had significant eruption the
disruptions in the supply chain and our
supply chain is so important with so
many materials that come from other
places
at the same time because the rescue plan
boosted the strength and speed of our
recovery
americans had more money in their
pockets
and during the pandemic
they wanted to spend that money not on
restaurants and vacations because of
covet
but on hard goods
home improvements televisions
automobiles
but
the lumber factories weren't open they
weren't making two by fours plywood
wasn't available i can go down the list
the very products that we needed for the
things they wanted to buy
are slowed down by disruptions in the
supply chain
so what happens prices went up
significantly
just look at automobiles
last year
automobiles the automobiles accounted
for one third of all the inflation in
america
because the auto companies couldn't get
the computer chips
the price of an automobile skyrocket
and now second big reason for inflation
is vladimir putin
and gas prices not a joke
we've seen the price of gas
go up over a dollar just since he put
his troops on the border
on the border of ukraine they went up a
dollar and five cents
big part of that reason is putin began
amassing troops along the border and
then crossed
and guess what the world took notice
the market anticipated prices went up
and then putin invaded
make no mistake
the current spike in gas prices is
largely the fault of vladimir putin
it has nothing to do with the american
rescue plan
back to wall street wall street
estimated that the and the san francisco
federal reserve said analyzed it said
the rescue plan contributed only
0.3 percent to inflation
0.3 percent
that's coming from the fed
rescuing our economy didn't cause this
problem
but we're working to fix it
we're building this economy from the
bottom up in the middle out
and something incredible is happening
we're seeing a manufacturing revival
like never before
the pride that comes from stamping
products made in america
that hold a minute one of the things you
should be aware of is a law i was
unaware of when i was a senator to be
honest with you
it's called made in america
as president united states i get to
allocate over 600 billion dollars in
spending
on federal
projects any federal project
president for since 1939
has been able to say
that entire program has to be made in
america before i'm going to pay for it
well guess what
53
55 of the product was made in america
was thought to be made in america
i'm changing that
i'm changing that
has to be a minimum of 75 and then
and then
because where in the hell is it written
saying we can't manufacture things in
america again i don't know where that's
written
and so guess what
intel came to me
they're going to yes by the way yes
chairman of the board came
they're going to invest 20 billion
dollars to build a factory in ohio
to manufacture computer chips
[Applause]
semiconductors
will power the world in our everyday
lives smartphones the internet
technology that doesn't even exist today
and they're prepared to increase that
investment from 20 billion to 100
billion dollars in the suburb of
cleveland
so now
[Applause]
create over 12 000 jobs
some of them just building the
facilities
but the rest
blue-collar workers making an average of
135
000 a year in these factories
and as soon as the congress
sends me the bipartisan innovation bill
a bill to invest another 52 billion in
computer chips i might add by the way
we invented the computer chip here in
america
we advance the computer chip here in
america then we stop making the computer
ship here in america
and that's going to bring down prices of
automobiles appliances and so much more
and that's not just intel so look it
forward at long discussion of ford and
general motors and the detroit factories
ford's committed
11 billion dollars to build electric
vehicles in america the biggest
investment they've ever made
gm has committed seven billion dollars
to build electric vehicles just a few
years ago these pumping these companies
might have built these factories
elsewhere not now they're building it
right here in the united states of
america again
well look
you also know there's much more than one
way to increase people's standard of
living
you can reduce the cost look right now
what's the problem again my dad used to
say people just need a little bit of
breathing room my dad was a a
not
my dad was just a wonderful decent
gentleman
whose greatest regret was he never went
to college
my dad
my dad used to talk about
how
middle-class folks whenever given a
chance had never ever ever let the
country down
never let the country down when they do
well everybody does well
but
look so gasoline prices home heating oil
prices are going to continue to go up
because of this these these embargoes on
russian oil and other things that he's
brought on but what happened
there's other ways
my dad used to talk about the standard
of living
it costs a lot more money if you have to
pay five bucks at a pump for a gallon of
gasoline
and it affects families big time
or to heat your home
but guess what
if you lower the cost of child care
it
affects your standard of living
and that's why we're going to make sure
no one has to pay more than seven
percent of their income on child care
over 200 000 kids in america and many
more adults with type 1 diabetes and
insulin every day
it costs 10 bucks to make a vial of
insulin
the average cost
647 dollars a month
up to a thousand
not gonna happen on my watch no one's
gonna have to be able to charge more
than 35 a month for insulin they'll
still make a big profit
the average family
when we pass the provision allowing for
tax credit for homeowners to
to uh to winterize their homes you can
save an average of 500 bucks a month
just by having doors that don't leak
windows that don't leak and so on
so look let me be clear
none of this will increase inflation
17 nobel prize winners in the in
economics
wrote to me
saying that would ease inflationary
presence
pressures
we can also do without raising a single
penny on tax of anybody making under
four hundred thousand dollars a year
you make less than four hundred
you're not going to pay a penny in tax
we have to do this by asking the top and
the biggest corporations to pay a little
more
look i'm a capitalist if you can make a
million or a billion bucks good for you
but pay your fair share pay a little bit
by the way
whether you're democrats or republicans
raise your hand if you think the tax
structure is fair now
look
55
i come from the corporate capital of the
world
you got it
well you think i'm kidding are more
corporations incorporated in delaware
than every other state in the union
combined
and i got elected seven times in
delaware notwithstanding the fact that
i'm so anti-corporate america
give me a break how long would i last
but here's the deal
55
for the largest corporations of fortune
500 paid zero in federal taxes last year
and they made 40 billion dollars in
profits
look i said i'm a capitalist that's not
about punishing anybody
but why in god's name
should a
billion-dollar corporation
pay a lower tax rate than a teacher or a
firefighter
folks
[Applause]
i really mean it
we can raise the standard of living for
hard-working families outraging taxes
without raising inflation without
raising the deficit let me remind
everybody
i actually last year cut the budget 300
billion dollars cutting the budget
and we're on track now to be the first
president history to have a lower
deficit by over one trillion dollars in
one year look folks
we can tackle these challenges
but we can't do without you
you understand what families are up
against
every time you walk down the street in
your neighborhoods you understand the
cost
if we fail to act
we need your voices
voice of local officials who understand
what your communities need
your senators and congressperson will
listen to you all
if you can get this done
we can get it done there's no limit
to what americans can achieve
so let's give working people the quality
they deserve quality of life
let's face the challenges ahead let's
keep building a better america
we can do this
thank you for taking the time
love you all
keep at it
thank you thank you thank you
thank you
thanks everybody
really man thank you
every time i'd walk out of my grandpop's
house up in scranton pennsylvania's name
was ambrose finning and yelled joey keep
the faith and my grandmother no joey
spread it go spread the faith let's get
it done thank you